how long were you in Iraq I was there
for a little over three weeks and we're
all did you go uh the we traveled mainly
around Tehran the city of Tehran I was
there in 1978 and traveled throughout
Iran but this fitness trip we were
mainly in Tehran you speak Farsi
I took about a year of Persian and
uc-berkeley I speak sort of passable
dinner-table Persian so that you're
pretty familiar with Iran and they're
just not somebody dropped in over there
and came back and suddenly is an instant
expert no on it well and so now you're
traveling around and telling people what
you got and having a show-and-tell
program you've got some documents here
yes once you show us what they have you
got these from the students at the
Embassy in Tehran the US Embassy in
Tehran these are documents that were
released by the students at the Embassy
and they were released to the media and
yet they've been suppressed I don't
think that people have really gotten a
chance to read through these because
they're very incriminating this one this
whole group of documents here is where
they're very interesting they're a
series of things for cover
considerations this one here this man
Paul Timmerman's apparently his cover is
a commercial business representative and
he was born in Belgium was he with the
CIA oh definitely yeah I mean they're
discussing how he should yeah you know
this is his background information then
he should be aware of what have you this
is not unusual though we're really not
surprising that there are CIA people
over there the CIA people intelligence
people in every embassy oh no I don't
think it's a big surprise I see the CIA
in Iran was not just reading newspapers
or doing this and that they were
actually engaging in sabotage engaging
in during the time of the Shah that they
would follow Iranian dissidents they
would turn them in and these people you
know were tortured to death or put in
prison and what-have-you when I talk to
the students at the Embassy they had
found loads and loads of counterfeit
Iranian money that was going to be used
to flood the Iranian economy and wreck
it
they found electronic spy equipment all
of the things that we are sure exist
inside the embassy but you know are used
against the Iranian people I think
another one of the significant things
that the US Embassy was used for is
was a central organizing place for
subversion and counter-revolution in
Iran and by that I mean that certain
embassy officers their job was to go out
to different courses before the
Revolution after during the revolution
and after revolution they were loyal to
the Shah and to organize them around the
the US has plans for a coup well hey
let's get to our like some more goodies
here what you got well this one here was
written in September 30th 1979 and it
basically is a discussion on bringing
the Shah it's subject Shah of Iran and
it's a discussion between the State
Department it's emanating from the
embassy to the State Department and it
says this I think this is very
interesting paragraph paragraph 4 says
given the kind of atmosphere and the
kind of public posturing about the Shah
by those who control or influence public
opinion here I doubt that the Shah being
ill would have any ameliorating effect
on the degree of reaction here it would
presumably make our own position more
defensible if we were seen to admit him
under demonstrably humanitarian
considerations so it was being arranged
way ahead it all yeah yeah and in fact
you know this is again this whole
question of the Shahs illness which was
the cover for bringing into the United
States is really to a large degree blows
that away in the sense that it's clear
that what they were trying to figure out
is what kind of face that put on he's
being brought here this one here is
particularly interesting because it is a
communique between Sullivan and the head
of the Bank of Omron Sullivan now is who
after him Sullivan was the ambassador to
Iran during the time of the shot and he
was there until the you know the
completion to certain degree the
completion of that portion of the
revolution in which the show was forced
to flee the country the bank of Omron is
the shelf personal bank okay and what
Sullivan is instructing this man to do
is to go into that to the bank of Omron
which is now being controlled by young
enthusiastic sort of revolutionary
monitoring Ron Ian's and
sort of go in there in Crete and wreak
havoc within this Bank a lot of places I
go people say are these really real and
I feel like saying what do you think I
get I went home and got seven different
typewriters and fabricated these
documents what purpose would that serve
yeah and that they're always referred to
in the sort of the normal the big press
or what have you as the alleged
documents these so-called
unauthenticated documents have to share
you with other media here in Austin you
have to go but hope you thank you very
much for having come back again this is
really great thank you very much Lisa
Radcliffe
so frequently in the media or in
discussions or the press we see things
like well so-and-so was a prisoner of
the Shah what was that really like it's
one thing to kind of well he was a
president even jail what was it really
like what does it do to a person and
what is the Iranian situation like now
and then it's difficult for us to get
good information in the United States
because it's filtered through the
regular establishment media mainly but
now we don't need that filtering because
we have chasm Allah who is poet writer
former political prisoner of the Shah
now living in Houston and will discuss
all these subjects with him and with us
is Kristie bird feather who's with crime
nothing illegal just means the coalition
against racism and intervention in the
Middle East they are very active on the
campus of the University because then in
a way I hesitate to ask you some of
these questions because I know it must
be very painful for you but can we go
back a few years ago what was it like in
Iran when the Shah was there I began to
be active in politics when I was in the
tenth grade of high school and we used
to have this kind of secret meetings in
our houses talking politics and
different subjects then we began to take
it to the high school like and we used
to have this wall newspaper in a wall
paper and I used to put my poetry on it
so they began to suppress it and they
expelled me from you know high school
for that reason the school was
suppressing it
yes but it was mainly because no support
was controlling everything there there
were these supervision committees in
every school supervision Committees of
Saavik the secret police every screws I
mean not only schools and factories I
mean everywhere offices you know they
had these supervision committees that
they were just having files on
everybody's activity and these several
times warned me that to not do that one
time they got me and I was entering the
inner school just before it we had an
exam in high school in high school and
they told me that if you go ahead harass
you and we do that and these to you and
leverages intimidating me and then when
you got to college you continued your
political activity yes when I enter the
college a just three months after I
entered the college and got arrested
what was the pretext I gave that we had
this mountain climbing organization in
University kind of sport organization
which was by the way in legal because
every kind of you know organization the
illegal especially universities and we
had these several students on a team
going to mountain climbing near Tehran
and they were lost and we knew they were
lost and we called the you know police
stations to get their help to send some
helicopters and get them it wasn't mean
to and excuse me they didn't give us any
damn help and then we sent another team
and we found their dead bodies they'd be
frozen you Saturday no student yes team
of students and when we brought their
bodies and everybody was outraged
because they could have sent helicopter
and saved their lives they didn't do
that and we had this funeral at a mosque
called AK mast and the boss was in the
center of Tehran near the bazaar
and lots of students several thousand I
can say from all the universities came
to that field rod and the army and the
police were surrounding us and the
attack was a kid one student and arrest
arrested about three hundred tears
including you including me and it was
about Christmas time and you know Turin
was very cold a street or sleepy tell
other words we beat you with one flag it
weeps oh yes feed cable actually take a
cable this T I mean probably 3/4 of inch
T and they shaved our you know hair and
just make us look very ugly and they
beat the hell other was all over your
body or our body well it was funny
everybody every of this our people
tortures would come and just to have fun
it was they were enjoying it just to
punch or to get one but somebody's ear
and pool and to other any I mean they
were just sadists in they loved it and
there was this guy called Hosseini who
used to just love torturing he was
saying you know they called me Hosseini
and have you heard my name I kill people
on the literature I burned it so just
tell me the truth do not you know play
around with me and you know just that
kind of thing and when you said well I
don't have nothing to say I don't know
why you have resume okay they would put
you on this bed of chick you know chairs
special tree with the hell out of you
mansion naked and you know do all kinds
of crazy things
but that first time they couldn't keep
us more than two months because first of
all it was math errors and all the
universities went on strike I mean then
the bazaar in Tehran and I've talked to
our support and then they were these all
kinds of solidarity messages from
factories and so they really got
harassed they really were scared to keep
us so after two months they freed most
of us they keep several but he freed
most of us they had you know some kind
of you know eyes on us and they live
nothing I mean after you after they
released you they still yes followed you
and kept track of what your yes I
believe so because the second time that
I got arrested about eleven month after
I was freed they know pretty I'm not all
of I did but they know a lot where I
went even they know sometimes that what
kind of movies I've watched you know
they have surveillance on your friends
also I believe so because they arrested
several of my friends too so after you
got out after what two months the first
time two months at six hundred
University they didn't want to accept us
at the universe and the University and
but you know our fellow students bent on
strike so they accepted us under this
condition that anytime we hear something
means the government you have to report
it to saw what and if they catch us on
something then we hereby admit that they
can do whatever they want to do so that
was the condition in which they accepted
you back into these girl you had to
become a sabaki Informer but you didn't
sign that he didn't sign a nobody sign
that he stayed away from university for
about two or three weeks
so this softened a position because the
university was still on strike and our
fellow students wanted us in so they
just got this piece of paper that I
promised not get involved in politics
and sign it so then they wanted our
parents to co-sign it so I mean and then
parents came and cosign didn't let us in
that was it but they leave it on
surveillance
we had several times V there several
times raided on you know campus badly I
mean really badly people got kid rated
bye-bye so Lauren in the Army and the
army liberated the campus they could get
anybody no matter he he or she was
involved in demonstration or they would
just get anybody that they did I just
make these raids Reds and get
interesting
yes and several of our students you know
got refuge on the roofs the fifth floor
the sixth one they threw them they just
threw them like garbage down and many
people got killed that way many people
had broken legs or arms or you know you
know just to say that anytime you
protest something that's that you know
the response you get so just shut up
and they did several times that and
several times they raided the
dormitories and but
well I didn't get arrested I mean be
escaped so you managed to not get
arrested for about another 11 months I
was the reason you were arrested in
prison second the second time we had
this floor students getting kid on the
dormitory and we just overnight we
decided to make a funeral for him and I
endure boy door with several other
students and raised money and got
people's you know support and asked him
to come and participate and he was you
know a native of Isfahan we had to go to
that city we move overnight given to
that city and with the help of the East
Valley University students we organized
a funeral funeral was you know forbidden
we didn't have funeral and getting the
body to the symmetry for against the law
it was probably gathering against the
law even the funeral was considered a
public gathering yes yes you couldn't
you know walk in the streets you know it
and people more than five or ten so the
police was everywhere
to prevent us but we really organized
that we got lots of support and people
just with peaceful of this kind of you
know operation they joined us I mean the
pastor price that they didn't know who
was keep in vivid saying you know
everybody joined the funeral yes I
started school I mean they couldn't
attack it it was just great I mean then
we began to say slogans against the show
we turned it to an entire show
demonstration and then we went to
symmetry we brought some statements
just talking to people and when we went
back for about a week and they began to
rest
everybody was suspicious you know being
involved or organizing his funeral and
they got me but the me they first did
not ask about that funeral they were
just saying okay now what kind of
affiliation do you have with this great
long movement they were just torturing
me for those reason you are a poet and
you are radical why did you read your
poetry for you you know friends you were
instigating riots I mean just this kind
of question so they were trying to get
you to confess the various types of
activity which you may or may not even
have been involved in that's troop and
the way they began to as they put it
themselves to work on me was and is
something that I can never forget I mean
it's just like a continuous night name
first
they made me complicated and they
searched everywhere I mean just
humiliating you know just playing with
your body and not only searching and
then they threw me to this solitary and
they said okay now you have 24 hours to
say everything yourself otherwise and we
work on you we know how to make you
confess and it was not just 24 hours it
was just being in the center of these
torture chambers hearing all of these
cries and screams coming everywhere I
mean I couldn't sleep a minute that 24
hours because of this you are in the
solitary disguise screaming kidding me
don't do that just kill me and this I
mean screams all over it
fill your ears
and once in a while is God coming and
looking through that hole to you and
suddenly opening to the what you doing
and this kind of you know just harassing
you then the next day the morning they
took me to this room that was filled
with blood you know very low ceiling and
there wasn't spared feel feet blood and
blood all over and scabs no I mean this
dried blood everywhere and this Smith
dirty filthy and they fastened me my
hands and my legs - no - deathbed half
naked and in this torture that first
came and introduced himself
his name was carrying me out I believe
it was his nickname it wasn't his real
name came and said you know I'm carry me
and I have killed lots of people who
resisted to confess now if you be good
boy you just say whatever you did you
know everything about you you just want
to hear it from your own mouth and but
if you are a bad boy then I can't
promise that you get away alive from
here so I said well I don't know what
you are talking about I never did that
thing or illegal thing so they call this
boy was a young probably eighteen ninety
years old soldier and they gave him
cable there were several cables with
different you know with and he was just
playing with me okay do you want this
thick or this cable or death cable and
they did one of them to that meets it
okay with him
they beep so bad they leave me about a
hundred flags and I get unconscious and
we poured water on me and especially
when they put water on my legs which had
blood bleeding and blood was springing
all over the ceiling and everywhere
it really was painful cord below and you
know cold water on it means and then
they keep me enforcement to walk jump on
my legs and then they repeated that I I
didn't say anything and this continued
for the whole day until evening I just
continued baby repeating other things
they stated other things like he left
the room this carry me guns towards this
soldier okay try to get something out of
his mouth I'll be back and carry me left
at the room and you know closed door the
soldier was just like finding kind of
bananas I just you know was getting my
testicles and just putting you know his
hands on my mouth and just opening my
mouth and I mean just like anyone I
couldn't believe that you know and I
mean there is a man a human being you
know it was just like anymore just he
told my bodies with his names and it was
then
I was difficult for you talking about it
horrible experience you don't have to if
you don't want to I have a duty to say
these things for American people to know
what was life I'll make sure so anyway
after about half an hour I was so badly
screaming that this carry me came and
just slap in the face that soldier said
we have not taken any words out of his
mouth we want him alive we don't want to
kill him now it was really killing me
and they gave me a break for about two
hours and the day again began started
again weeping and not they did something
with my fingers that I was thinking that
they are breaking it I I don't know how
they did it but I mean the pain was
scratching all over my bones it was
offered and then they couldn't get any
word and I was bleeding all over my nose
was bleeding my mouth was bleeding blood
was all over my body and so they thought
that's enough for that day then they
asked me to walk to my solitary I
couldn't walk so I said and somebody got
my
cuz and pulled me all the way I'm sorry
to the solitaire and then they began
this I mean they didn't stop torturing
just taking me to solid they didn't let
me sleep for five continents days and
nights any time I kind of failed to
asleep somebody came and slept very bad
in the face oi
then discontinued the next idea came
took me in that chamber and this time
they handcuffed me this way and there
was this hook that they hooked me to
death
and they could raise it so I could be
kind of hang of the grass and the pain
part of it
they did it
several times then they treated me beep
raping me raping you
they treat and they didn't break but
they treatin I'll pretend they were
going yes they pretend they are going to
ride me they made me naked and there
were the strong torturers coming in
playing and saying okay you're you want
to be no have fun with you and well I
was so torn that I wouldn't I mean it
wouldn't make any difference for me
because I was thinking that I'm connect
our unit out or so I was thinking so I
didn't react it that was your thing
couldn't do such a terrible thing to me
I just looked at so they saw no reaction
no it was probably just kind of saying
okay you're in a state of shock so they
didn't do it but then I was you know for
47 days in death solitary dirty filthy
small solitary I couldn't go to bathroom
I didn't take a shower for the whole
time and I was stinky blood was dried
blood was all over my body I didn't have
control over my body I urinated blood
and through our blood in
they were of these horrible moments at
in the middle of the night a with
sometimes comment shake you up and say
okay and your execution order has been
issued now confidence and just blindfold
you and take you to a place that you
hear you know gunshot and gone five and
sometimes close you to it you know
bought something three or because you
were blindfolded I couldn't realize what
was that they would tie you to hi you to
some three years that's host or
something and then you you would I mean
you were really that you get kid and you
were I was reading to get keep I mean I
was so much on the pressure and death
would be I mean just relief and did did
they take you back to the to solitary do
nothing you know just psychologically
faith and
I remember that my wounds on my palms
began to infect and I several times
knock the door and asked them for
medical care they came and beat me
instead of giving medical care then by
that time they couldn't have gotten
anything booked any word against me they
forced some some of my friends to
confess things against me that I did not
admit and I was fortunate that then they
arrested me
everybody knew I was arrested so my
friends went to my house and just empty
it they think you know there's any thing
for the salt salt later seriously they
didn't give anything when you were in a
Cell what kind of conditions were there
any rats or bugs of anything like that
or was it sealed off so at least we
protected someone it was very dirty I
had a very bloody stinky blanket and
that was the only thing I had no pillows
nothing and it was cold
roaches were everywhere that's don't I
mean the horror of these roaches just
walking through my rooms and you know
eating my body was I can never recover
from that
how are you finally released well for I
was in a very bad situation that
solitary and then they took me
this means that really being infected so
they caught the tissues with a scissor
and put some bandage and then took me to
public you know prison out of solitary I
was there for about 10 months ago body
prison and did they continue beating you
there no just a regular prison no but
they had this regular rates on the
prison he didn't have any any pen or
paper or something so anytime they every
week or every other week they would
trade the prison and beat us and look
for pen or pencil because they were
afraid that somebody who had a visitor
might have brought something but it was
impossible to bring a pen
I had only two visits by my family they
didn't know that I was ji mean I was
alive they they were told that I was
executed and they were told that I was
you know kid differently not executed I
mean they were saying all these kinds of
Lies to my family and several times my
family became men came and asked to
visit me they beaten and beat your
parents became physically
just harassing that your son was and it
gorilla in the terrorist and he's keen
and now if you come one more time here
we'll take you to the same place and
this kind of harassment and I after
seven months I had a visit and but for
one thing they got I mean they were
crying and they saw me but it was just
something for that they saw me lie I
couldn't watch now for one year and I
couldn't really walk and run like a
normal person you know these bones I
said you know my Paul modesty kind of
strange they are not not smooth you know
if it's a man indeed they are like small
hands all over it because they caught
the teacher he's very bad
then after eleven months
I got at rod it was pretty funny but
trial in military core you know the
presentation and I mean that was just a
mockery of trial my the guy that was
supposed to defend he was a major a
colony in the army and he came and told
other charges were also military
officers and told it was a secret
tribunal and he told him well I believe
that this
who is guilty I'm ashamed representing
we feed them we give them education and
now they protest I mean he was worse
than the prosecutor so they convicted me
to two years NJ I appealed and it was by
the time that the international pressure
was really on on the show and his regime
to release his political prisoners and
they were protests all over the world so
the second time I had this chance to
have a civil attorney and he decreased
the conviction by one year but after one
year they didn't release me they were
saying well we are not going to release
you because you didn't confess that they
still beat you during that year or they
just made you locked up no they didn't
beat me they just keep in love and so
after my conviction was all of my
sentence was over for ten days every day
they took me to the you know what she
called Khalid basement just to talk to
me some way you know just telling me we
won't release you on this you sign that
you would cooperate
it is a walk-in it was the same time
several other of my friends they're all
spinaroonie and they would take us
together you you know just be nice no
see if you we can't release you we can
pay you a good salary you can be have a
good position afternoon Treasury than
all of this kind he cooperated if you
operate so then they said no we thank
you
and they said well okay now we won't let
you out or even if you are out you won't
be accepted in how you know college
again so we were saying all of us that
you don't want to go back to that
College Monica
on some job and you know just anything
they said this refused they said we
won't let you in Ducati okay we are not
going to go back to college any and they
said we won't let you to work anywhere
yeah okay my I said I'm going to help my
father in his job I am not worried about
finding a job you cannot did my father
to not give me a job so and after this
10 days conversation taking awesome back
and forth they forced us to sign this
thing that okay we release you on the
dis condition that every month you
report to police you where were you who
were you contacted me you know where did
you go on this kind of things and if you
wanted to move from one city to another
city you have to report designed that
but we never ready you know did that
nobody reported so that was the reason
that after they returned they released
us the second time every other month
they used to come and pick us at the
gate of the university or somebody in
between the University and the house and
just you know interrogate for one or two
hours they're very you these activities
that you were involved in which were the
pretense forgetting you're arrested were
activities that were happening all over
Iran at the time hundreds of thousands
of people yes well we had hundreds of
thousands of political prisoners - and
the number of people who were tortured
imprisoned and tortured under the Shah
also must have reached from what I've
read hundreds of thousands Hanzel if you
were lucky enough to stay on the cross
intersection and not get arrested not
because if you were staying for no
reason someplace they would get
suspicious and think that you
the date with the gorillas because they
were suspicious they they logic was that
you're suspicious of anybody on this the
opposite is proved everybody is guilty
unless it's I'm in the con contraries
prove the opposite is proof so if you
had to stay them you know couldn't stay
one place and one day you will see this
our cars passing by and just picking up
in the youth for no reason or cinching
them on the wall and taking it I mean
just those people would disappear they
shall spend several times more on
building prisons and building libraries
or schools or from this Ruby name and we
had in every major city we had big
prisons cabs really big prisons
thousands of prisoners and in only
Tehran we had three big prisons for and
in my prison probably we estimated there
were about seven thousand so if you just
see in Tehran they were about something
like 25,000 prisoners and they were only
the prisoners who were in the prisons
the saw walk had these headquarters in
every other neighborhood or you know
just different headquarters that they
had again you know death chambers and
you know the many of them very exposed
after the Revolution people just found
him with dead bodies all over with
torture tools everywhere so I I want to
say if in one city you have 25 estimate
trough estimate 25 or 30 thousand
prisoners then we had so many prisons
all over the Iran they had big prisons
with thousands of prisons in Mashhad
with her we had huge prison in isfahan
which this one was a working class in
our city and they were unrest there so
just to show you how big did
this prison is fun was the building's
for the personal of the prison was
enough for a thousand families it is for
the people who ran the prison Greenup
was enough for a thousand family you got
to see this thing there in this farm and
so you can have you know estimate of the
dimension of the prison and then the add
prison in harsh we had prisons I mean
probably 100 cities we had prisons so
just kidding this to me was awful
well it's no wonder then that the people
of Iran mistrust the US government a wee
bit well because because it was the US
government all this time the CIA was
supporting and training soo bahk and
they said they were supporting and
training the army and the government was
supporting the policies of the Shah
right up to the end yes you never heard
anything about shock what was shot doing
in your neighborhood is he here in mass
media here in United States they were
all supporting him he was really puppet
for the interest he was thing good for
them and the multinational corporations
and the multinational banks the
Rockefeller banks were just making
billions of dollars and it's billions of
dollars and for wanting let me tell you
this that Americans in Iran we were
Iranian citizen what we had second-class
citizen she was dead as comparing two
Americans they were places that they
were no your onions very allowed to go
also clubs you can only Americans could
go there they had facilities I mean
fascinating facilities on the time that
the housing was a major problem for
Iranian people and
timings of 15 or 20 we're living in one
big room in shantytowns covered with
this metal plate and you know which is
very hot in summer and very cold in
winter and people freezing to death in
winters sure was making building
beautiful partners beautiful villas for
Americans
we had 40,000 military advisers United
States military was training secret
police and are not only training a
secret police and army but actually
helping him to you know this finding the
Intel shore fighters places and gunning
him down and torturing them to training
them torture techniques just a few
months ago one of these tortures was
confessing before the international
journalists in Tehran and he said that
he got his the trainees in the United
States did several other tortures they
had this they were all the way behind
the shot all the way back him and only
when clean you know was so bad that they
couldn't hide it they began to say to
portray what was going on Iran but in
the way that well these fanatics are
over truly modernizing right he's crazy
people are always throwing out his joy
so wonderful and these people are just
fanatics Muslim fanatics crazy people
and just even than they were they were
giving coverage about what was going on
in Iran they were giving this kind of
coverage and you find that when you came
to the United States that most of the
people agreed with this position I
assume most of the people thought the
Shah was ok Amenti most of the people
that I saw they were
thinking that all expressing they can't
believe Shah was a bad because all they
have heard is that sure was a great God
moderniser everybody loved him in the
country and this only a few bunch of
fanatics and communists hate him I have
had really good conversation with many
Americans for one thing if they knew the
truth
they'll comment there cause you had the
same thing happening two centuries ago
you had a British Empire's
domination here you had you were
oppressed so that was the cause for the
first revolution here so it is not a
crazy act to make a revolution when you
want to get rid of foreign country's
domination and control over your lives
you also had your second revolution
civil war that broke out because because
of you know struggling for civil rights
and thousands of thousands people shared
their blood and it wasn't crazy thing so
now that you're doing the same thing and
we are crazy and you did that a hundred
years ago and it is you shouldn't have
this problem now you should have get rid
of our tyrants and dictators 50 years
ago if it wasn't United States
government and other foreign countries
involvement what what about the Soviet
Union and Iran there's a lot of hysteria
war hysteria cold war hysteria
anti-soviet imagine a lot of people
would want wonder what the relationship
is with Iran and the Soviet Union they
say all the Soviet Union has troops only
300 miles from the refineries and the
Soviets are going to move into Iran what
do you think about that you know any any
country who was in the side of the short
people hated Soviet Union's burocracy at
the time that show us massacring people
arson
messages of congratulation for his
birthdays exaggerating the show yes so
people I mean they're identified this
Pro crowds with the shot and they hated
him I don't believe that Soviet Union
has any intention to intervene in Iran
and even though this the calm person
government of Iran tries to say so to
mobilize the people and say that now we
are really in danger that so being is
just 30 miles from but we had also 1,400
miles Bordelaise August evening for st.
I mean for all of our live and nothing
happening so they are not going into it
and I mean people are not that you know
scared in the Soviet Union
right the Russians saw what the Iranians
did ringing people did to the Shah I'm
sure they don't want to tackle that and
they are not looking for problem
no because them I wish we could talk
much longer about this I know we're
running out of time and you have to get
back to Houston I do want to thank you
for sharing your experiences I realize
it was very painful for you and quite
frankly it was painful for Christie and
I to be here
I just hope like you say that the
American people can hear and understand
and appreciate what the Iranian people
have gone through as a country is and as
individuals they can understand the part
that the US government then the US
corporations have played in Iran just
understand that's about all you really
want isn't it
that's what they want and I also want to
thank you for giving me this opportunity
Thank You say something thank you very
much